[Musique]
on
ange 2022 l'heure du choix avec vous
antoine verdien bonjour bonsoir raphaël
j - 17 avant le premier tour alors que
la guerre en ukraine et ses conséquences
ont la vue continue de dominer
l'actualité
les thèmes plus classique de campagne
tente également d'exister les retraités
étaient dans la rue ce jeudi à l'appel
de neuf organisations pour réclamer une
hausse de leur pension dans un contexte
de hausse des prix rassemblement à paris
à lyon marseille ou encore à bastia en
corse la corse où l'hommage rendu à yvan
colonna hier continue de faire réagir
les candidats le récap politique est
signée florent rodo et julia vous dit
c'est l'histoire d'un accueil aussi
impressionnant que polémique la corse
rend un hommage remarqué à yvan colonna
l'assassin du préfet erignac en 1998 sur
place drapeaux mis en berne une faute
selon emmanuel macron sentiment partagé
par anne hidalgo franchement les
drapeaux en berne là je crois que c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement jumelles ont
choqué lui les par total énergie pour
yannick jadot le pétrolier français
rester en russie est complice de crimes
de guerre résultat une plainte du groupe
contre l'écologiste pas vraiment
impressionné
on a toujours eu les menaces des lobbys
ça n'a jamais cessé ces lobbys qui
dirige le pays ça suffit cette guerre en
ukraine selon nathalie arthaud de lutte
ouvrière c'est le symbole des méfaits de
l'impérialisme bruce comme américain je
renvoie dos à dos poutine hebeisen je ne
marche pas dans cette caricature
l'acquis qui quoi qui présente en gros
le camp occidental comme comme les
bienfaiteurs les bienfaiteurs de
l'humanité mais ou dites moi ou
augmenter le pouvoir d'achat des
français ils y travaillent la solution
de jean luc mélenchon un smic à 1400
euros net par mois coût de la mesure 250
milliards d'euros avec l'insoumis les
plus fortunés ont de quoi s'inquiéter si
vous voulez on a un problème en france
les riches ne coûte trop cher
donc il faut qu'ils mettent la main à la
poche arrive de créer des emplois aussi
les riches il faut partager écouter
c'est une situation de crise totale donc
là c'est la crise totale tout le monde
se serre les coudes voilà
eux doivent se serrer la ceinture pour
joindre les deux bouts les retraités
veulent peser sur la campagne et surtout
avoir de meilleures pensions des
revendications qu'ils n'avaient pas été
entendus lorsque edouard philippe était
le premier ministre d'emmanuel macron ça
n'existe pas les bilan parfait il était
sur scène à nice en soutien du président
candidat
tout peut se passer en 18 jours voilà
c'est tout pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve demain
et il ne manquait plus que ça la
candidate des républicains valérie
pécresse poney quatrième ou cinquième
dans les intentions de vote selon les
sondages malgré les efforts déployés
pour remonter la pente ce jeudi elle
annonce donc avoir contracté le
coronavirus annulation du coût de ces
déplacements à bordeaux demain et à
marseille samedi mais elle assure
continuer sa campagne à distance valérie
pécresse qui a par ailleurs présenté
aujourd'hui son projet de loi
constitutionnelle pour dit-elle rétablir
l'ordre en france parmi ces propositions
des peines minimales obligé la loi pour
certaines infractions graves comme pour
les agressions de policiers au d'élus un
mois après le début de la guerre en
ukraine 3 sommet avait lieu aujourd'hui
à bruxelles concomitamment celui
de l'otan de du g7 et de l'union
européenne et c'est celui de l'otan qui
va nous intéresser parce que l'alliance
1 est désigné par plusieurs candidats à
cette élection comme au moins en partie
responsable de cette guerre oui la
question de l'appartenance de la france
au commandement intégré de l'alliance
dirigée par les états unis a été remis
sur la table par certains candidats à la
présidentielle qui disent ne pas vouloir
être poussé dans des guerres qui ne sont
pas selon eux celle de la france ont
fait le point ce soir avec notre
chroniqueuse internationale virginie
herz bonsoir virginie alors quels sont
les positionnements des différents
candidats à la présidentielle sur cette
histoire de l'appartenance de la france
au commandement intégré de l'otan alors
si vous permettez un petit rappel
historique h rennes en 1949 la france
fait partie des membres fondateurs de
l'otan l'organisation du traité
atlantique nord qui une alliance
militaire défensif faire face à l'union
soviétique et son expansionnisme dans un
contexte de guerre froide naissante
quarante ans plus tard l'union
soviétique s'effondre le rideau de fer
se brise et l'otan on va le voir sur la
carte s'élargit au fur et à mesure vers
l'est aujourd'hui il y a trente et mata
membres les états unis évidemment 29
pays européens turquie comprise et en
jaune voyait certains pays candidats ou
qui aimeraient l'être le principe est
celui donc de la défense collective si
un membre est agressé il peut au nom de
l'article 5 de demander à tous les
autres une réaction commune alors ce
n'est pas obligé ce n'est pas
automatique mais ça donne certaines
garanties certaines assurances et ses
décisions sont ensuite discutées au sein
du fameux commandement intégré de l'otan
alors dans l'histoire de france on en a
entendu parler c'est en 1966 le général
de gaulle quitte avec fracas ce
commandement intégré on va peut-être
voir les archives au nom de la
souveraineté la souveraineté nucléaire
notamment le voilà du général de gaulle
en 2009 nicolas sarkozy lui décide de sa
réintégration alors ce qui est
surprenant c'est que intégration pas
dans ce fameux commandement eux intégrés
qui fixe les stratégies et fait
appliquer les fait appliquer sur le
terrain c'est que finalement on sait pas
vraiment quelles sont les conséquences
très très très concrète mais pourtant
aujourd'hui plus de la moitié des
candidats veulent quitter ce fameux
commandement c'est grey on va aller voir
sur cette carte en rouge voilà une
majorité qui sont donc pour pour le pour
le quitter au nom de la souveraineté et
de l'indépendance des décisions de
politique de défense de lundi en perd
yayisme de la méfiance envers les états
unis les états unis qui je vous le
rappelle ne se sont pas privés de se
retirer par exemple d'afghanistan sans
en avertir ses alliés
en revanche des candidats +30 centristes
ne voit pas la nécessité de ce retrait
on les voit ici en verre et au contraire
ils s'inscrivent plutôt dans un
renforcement de l'otan mais à chaque
fois en disant qu'ils veulent aussi
renforcer la défense européenne à la
guerre en ukraine a relancé le débat
virginie alors relancé le débat aussi
sur le budget militaire très
spécifiquement alors vous savez que la
france comme les autres membres pays de
l'otan s'engage à consacrer 2% de son
pib à la défense avec c'était l'objectif
de 2020 qui a été retenu mais certains
candidats veulent aller plus loin que ça
on va le voir ici alors c'est le code
notamment des candidats de droite en
verre comme nicolas dupont aignan qui
veut avoir 2 25% du pib qui est consacré
à la défense pour notamment recruté 40 à
50 mille soldats supplémentaires
intensifier la lutte contre le
terrorisme à l'extérieur de nos
frontières et protéger les chrétiens
d'orient je le cite marine le pen elle
veut augmenter le budget de la défense
de 14 milliards d'ici 2027 c'est-à-dire
de cinq ans et eric zemmour lui plus de
30 milliards d'euros d'ici 2030
notamment pour financer un deuxième
porte avions alors à l'opposé vous avez
dans une tradition anti militariste de
gauche nathalie arthaud lo et philippe
poutou qui ne veulent pas augmenter ce
budget de la défense des noces ont au
passage l'enrichissement du complexe
militaro industriel
l'un comme l'autre veulent réduire
pouvoir retirer tout simplement les
troupes françaises à l'étranger c'est le
cas aussi de fabien roussel quant aux
candidats restants le il met en avant
d'autres priorités par exemple plus de
contrôle démocratique sur les opérations
militaires extérieures c'est le cas
notamment d'anne hidalgo de jean
lassalle ou bien encore une ald une
armée pardon plus adaptée aux défis
climatiques c'est les propositions de
yannick jadot et de jean-luc mélenchon
merci beaucoup vers gênés on se retrouve
dès jeudi prochain pour un nouveau
décryptage suite de notre série de
portraits à présent sur les candidats
oui la coutume de dire que la politique
s'est imposé à elle dès la plus tendre
enfance marine le pen a d'abord évolué
évoluer sous l'ailé protectrice de son
père jean-marie fondateur du front
national
d'inspirant il deviendra bientôt
encombrants ils sont détachera
progressivement à mesure que ses
ambitions personnelles prendront le
dessus battu au second tour en 2017 elle
pense aujourd'hui que l'heure de la
revanche a sonné son portrait signé
florence
[Musique]
elle est tombée dedans quand elle était
toute petite
la politique chez marine le pen une
affaire de famille il faut dire que son
père jean marie est aussi celui du front
national parti d'extrême droite à chaque
fois qu'il est attaqué marine le défend
une vocation est née elle sera avocate
chasser la politique elle revient au
galop
en 1998 premier mandat local conseillère
régionale du nord-pas-de-calais
le père voit en elle la relève je crois
que marine est doux et enfin de la
politique adoubée elle entame sa mission
adoucir l'image du paternel et marquer
sa différence tu marine le pen 1 j'ai
toujours été marine le pen et je
resterai marine le pen c'est ça aussi
l'intérêt je ne suis pas un clown de mon
père énorme surprise jean marie le pen
21 avril 2002 jean marie le pen l'a fait
pleurer l'en remercie il est au second
tour face à jacques chirac la fille
monte en grade et en 2011 son heure
sonne la commandante du paquebot
familiale c'est elle désormais mot
d'ordre la dédiabolisation de son front
national on soit hommes-femmes chrétien
juif musulman hétérosexuels homosexuels
non croyant on est d'abord français
stratégie payante
la base électorale s'élargit en 2014 le
parti gagne les européennes rafle une
dizaine de mairie plus de 1500 postes de
conseillers municipaux aussi
vient l'heure de tuer le père
politiquement elle les gect du parti
qu'il a lui même fondé c'est la fracture
on ne reverra pas ces deux là ensemble
sur scène
pour sa deuxième présidentielle en 2017
marine le pen égale son père défaite au
second tour face à emmanuel macron
l'union européenne va mourir pour gagner
il faut alors changé la maison à
commencer par la façade exit le front
national bienvenue le rassemblement
national
marine le pen voulait sortir de lieux et
de l'euro aux oubliettes le rn se veut
moins radicale le père jean-marie cria
la faute son nouveau poulain sa
petite-fille marion maréchal
la politique encore et toujours une
affaire de famille
et c'est tout pour ce soir fel merci h
rennes france 2022 l'heure du choix on
vous retrouve demain à la même heure et
nous eh bien on se retrouve dans moins
de trois minutes pour un nouveau journal
dans paris
[Musique]